we've reached a milestone a milestone  it's a historic moment for our country  and I am so proud that a woman a woman  will be in charge of our nation's secret  kill list  well preside over the warrantless mass  surveillance of ordinary citizens a  woman will direct our drone  assassination program finally it will be  a woman it's at that time we had a  female overseeing a huge expansion of  regulatory burdens and the huge  expansion of entitlement spending  the military's been of executive power  of federal debt it will finally be a  woman who helps destabilize the Middle  East it's finally a woman's job to  disregard the Constitution to keep  throwing money at education policies  that never yield result how blatant  falsehoods about transparency while  punishing whistleblowers at long last  our wealthy and dicted paranoid  narcissistic power-hungry president will  have a vagina a vagina will have a  vagina this changes everything